how am I going to turn whatever feeling
or idea I have into a story how are they
doing that what is the magic sauce if I
got in a car the most beautiful car in
the world turn on the key it doesn't
work I don't want the car it's got to go
what makes the car go that's a big
question that's a great question because
that's at the core of everything you
have now this energy that's like just
glowing inside of you to create I just
could not let it go it was a story I had
to tell start by understanding what
elements it takes to have a story but
every story is really about a problem
every story is about a character trying
to accomplish something and having an
obstacle and what they do what action
they take in the face of the obstacles
is your story if you don't have those
basic elements and that's not the whole
story obviously but if you don't have
those basic elements then then really
what is the story you don't have a
character to sort of be our vehicle
through a series of events and you don't
have anything propelling them forward or
driving them forward if they're not
trying to achieve something every story
creates a dramatic question and the
dramatic question is will the person get
what they want or not and that's what
holds us to the story I'm here because
something is changing for them and I now
need to watch them to struggle through
it grow through it whatever is going to
happen on that Journey that's why I'm
here in other words your protagonist
goes through a series of experiences
that lead to a transformation
transformation in a story is a key
element and whether it comes through
your main character or your main
character changing
um everyone else it doesn't matter it's
just that transformation is actually the
purpose of the story
it's actually the purpose of the story
because the reason we tell stories is to
actually understand ourselves better
and that Insight is a transformation for
us I believe any story is really about
how a character trying to accomplish
something runs into other people who
either help or harm their intention it's
because characters have been in trouble
characters have had a conflict
characters had to discover things about
themselves that they didn't want to look
at something happened they you know it
that's what makes drama they're kind of
struggling suffering being punished by
the situation they're in the upside down
World they find themselves in the
problem or goal that they're trying to
resolve which they're an underdog and
they're overmatched and the world is not
giving them what they want what are they
doing to try to get it how does that
make them face something in themselves
and how do they grow and do they finally
get this thing or do they get it in a
way that they didn't expect if we know
what that character is trying to achieve
that gives us like a yardstick to
measure is he succeeding or is he
failing is he making progress or is he
had having setbacks right and that's the
that's that like push-pull of like hope
and fear that we have when we're
watching the movie is we're hoping that
he makes progress and gets to his
destination but we're fearing the worst
we're fearing all these obstacles are
going to derail him or you know
um end up you know damaging him in some
way we don't want our heroes to resolve
things easily you know we want them to
struggle we want them to fight you know
we want we want us we want them to show
the strength that we wish we had or that
we believe that we have if somebody has
a goal and they go after it and they get
it we're like okay the story's over
their flaws can be just as important to
that process as their strengths in fact
probably more so because
if they're put into something that's
playing perfectly to their strengths
then it's probably too easy for them
it's their flaws that make it
interesting it's so good to have a
character that has a flaw because then
they make mistakes which creates more
conflict and then they do things out of
fear which allows us to understand them
more deeply if your character doesn't
have a flaw that they need to overcome
it's going to be difficult I think as a
Storyteller to figure out the journey
that they need to go on to
overcome that flaw whatever your idea is
is probably the thing that's going to
come to you first the most important
part of the process most writers bypass
too quickly which is selecting the idea
and understanding what makes a viable
idea every day
you should be thinking about story ideas
because there's some ideas you you know
just come up with a mat throw it away
you know it's pretty good but it's not
great but the ones that keep reoccurring
you know are the ones that you know I I
feel like okay I gotta work on this
there's something here they're out there
all over the place they're in newspaper
articles they're in conversations you
hear with people at the coffee shop
they're on the radio if I come up with
one idea that's one idea and it could be
a terrible idea if I come up with a
hundred ideas or 60 ideas or whatever I
can comb through and find the very best
idea and eventually when you reach that
past the 10 or 12 15 all the way up to
20 you'll start getting some really
original ways because you forced
yourself and so that's that's what the
writer needs to do you got to force
yourself to go deeper in order to create
some original writing I think you know
that it's working when you're like you
know oh I really want to keep you know I
want to keep going I want to know I
personally want to know what happens
next so I'm going to pick it apart first
I want to find all the flaws with
whatever ideas the idea is and try to
get past those flaws and and remove them
so that the idea is great this is why
you have a good idea yeah not when
people go that's great when they think
about it for about three seconds and
they go oh that's good that's when you
know it's actually connecting with
people
so you know if you have an idea and you
say that to 10 people and they kind of
all go oh they ask you about it again
later you know it's a good idea the
first process is getting the log line
down what's a log line for your story
and that's just a really one sentence
way to be able to encapsulate your plot
and in a way that's interesting it makes
people want to read your script boiling
it down to a sentence that you can pitch
to somebody like what's it about and you
know people get it right away um if I
can I come up with a log line
and I kind of use that as my North Star
that way I remember okay it's always
about this moment that may change over
time okay so how do we craft it every
writer has to find their own process the
first
important thing about your process is
recognizing that it's yours that there
is not a right or wrong way
um some people write at night some
people write in the day some people
write in short bursts some people write
in long extended verse it's there's no
particular Better or Worse process the
important thing about a process is
something that you can do relatively
easily for whatever reason it works for
you and that means you have to spend
time paying attention to yourself trying
different things and seeing which ones
work and which ones don't work you have
to figure out what works well for you
it's always better to try and do some
work and see how it goes you'll never
get to the place where you absolutely
know that you can write and then you
start writing it's always a question of
let me try this see what comes out do
not care about doing anything wrong
just spill your guts there's an idea for
something that I want to write great
what do I want to say what's the theme
so I go there first what do you want to
write about like what's your idea and
they probably have the idea I usually
have an idea or a concept or a story I
kind of want to tell and and in writing
it I find the characters I find the
story give me three words about the
story it could be just three three words
Revenge
um another word so we'll we'll start
with those words then give me a
character what's the character's job
what does that person do
and what does that character want to do
I always like to break down what they
want into two parts like they have an
emotional need like to find love or
connection or for revenge or power or
whatever and then there's a specific
immediate goal that they pursue in the
story that satisfies that emotional need
it usually just starts with one scene
where I'll see that so Crystal Clear
it's one of my favorite moments of the
creation process when I'm starting to
write it's not coming from a
from a starting place it's coming from a
scene I already had so I write that
scene out the most Vivid thing about
what I think about this idea I write
that scene out without any it doesn't
have to fit anywhere I don't know where
this is but I just see these characters
doing this at some point I don't want to
know the whole story beat by beat by
beat because I figured some things out
along the way that I would have never
thought of now there's other times I've
kind of thought the whole thing out
almost you know in in more you know
bigger beats and bigger sections but
that's usually what it is I know the
First Act How It Ends what happens in
the middle and then what happens to the
end for some people they only need to
know a g m and Z right I need to know a
through z so my outlines are long and
people usually know what the end is
people usually kind of know what the
setup is and they kind of know what the
resolution is where's it ending where
are we going I know
whether it is going to be happy or sad
and sometimes it has a happy ending
where the character
triumphs learns to deal with it and
sometimes it has a tragic ending where
the character
is unable to deal with it eventually
something will end it either the end
will be I don't get it or I do get it
and whatever they do that they had never
tried before is How It Ends because if
they had tried it before it would end
before I think the way you start is so
much more important because your end
organically comes from your beginning
what I want to have them in and then I
start them with the exact opposite in
the very beginning so I have two pieces
that I need I know I need an exciting
incident what sets them off on their
Journey there has to be an exciting
incident something has to come in and
make change cause problems cause a goal
that needs to be achieved at the
beginning of the story your character
may want something that they don't have
right and they're just kind of living
their life but we get the sense that
they want something that they don't have
and then there is this inciting incident
or Call to Adventure where maybe they
have the chance
to get what they want but it's like
super scary then I need a midpoint so
kind of twist that happens in the middle
and then I need an all this lost moment
so I have those five points and then
from there I go ahead and I I start
making beats so I knowing that I need to
get to these Five Points
then I begin to create a beat sheet and
the beat sheet is literally just okay
then this happens and then this happens
and then this happens and then meet this
person then this happens writing is a
process of questions that like if I
could there's a couple of things that I
wish I could like get tattooed on the
inside of people's eyelids that they
knew thinking scenes and writing is a
process of questions it's not a thing
you have to fill out it's not a form
that you have to fit into writing is a
question is always a process of having
something it could be just I want to
write a western or I want to talk about
how Love Hurts or I want to talk about
how love saved my life whatever it is
that you start with then you start to
ask questions
how am I going to tell this story am I
going to tell it through a character who
gets it or a story that doesn't get it
everything is going to be a choice every
question that you ask if you write down
that question
how am I going to tell this story who is
the main character everything is a
question and those questions are who's
it about what do they want why can't
they get it what do they do about that
why doesn't that work how does it end
those six questions basically will help
you write anything you should have
already asked the questions who is my
hero what is the hero's wound what are
they afraid of what is their visible
goal all these questions that you set up
in the story is really what holds us to
the story and so you know in setting up
your character you don't want to just
tell us a bunch of stuff about the
character you know maybe we see them do
something and we go
that's weird why are they doing that and
we keep wondering that until later we
get the answer to that question as as we
start to fully understand kind of who
this person is and why they are the way
they are before you even start writing
the words of the scene you want to step
back and as usual my suggest my advice
is ask questions so how do you make a
good scene work every time you ask a
question and you get a specific answer
you're moving closer to writing a scene
the number one thing I think when it
comes to scene work is Clarity of goals
and Stakes
Clarity Stakes are really important for
characters because they create suspense
and tension around the goal right so if
they don't achieve what they want to
achieve something terrible will happen
they will lose something it's
interesting how often writers tend to
write scenes of characters kind of
getting along and kind of having
victories
and I S and I usually say that you know
in a story The victories generally only
come at the very end if they come
anywhere other than the very end they're
usually very short-lived and often
overshadowed by the bigger problem that
still demands resolution because what
keeps the drama or the comedy moving is
that sense of there's a problem I'm
trying to solve this problem there's
this goal I'm trying to reach this goal
each scene has to move the story forward
and conflict will kind of ebb and flow
but there always has to be tension in
the story the next question you want to
ask is what does my character want in
this scene
and does that desire is that desire
going to her do they think it's going to
move them closer to their goal or at
least overcome an obstacle to achieving
their goal if the answer to that
question is no then the scene should be
jettisoned it's not serving the story
because every scene has to move the
character closer to their visible goal
or
force them to face an obstacle or
anticipate an obstacle that they didn't
know they were going to previously then
I'll go back after a day and I'll start
looking at it and I'll go back into each
of these scenes and I make sure like is
there are there nuances in there am I
did I write too much is there's too many
words you know once you you've looked at
that scene and you kind of areas the
rest of the story starting to fall into
place do I see what's going to be
happening now in this story if the
answer is yes keep going to make sure
that it makes sense that based upon
these beats or these scenes
this character is changing and they're
making decisions and there's conflict
and who's com you know who's creating
the conflict and I start I I start
coming up with characters that can help
to drive this protagonist one way or the
other and because every scene is
supposed to be cause and effect what
happens in this scene is because of what
happened in that scene then looking at
that beat sheet lets you know these are
the scenes that I need to get to the
next beat and these are the scenes that
I need to get to the next beat because
you know that the point is I need to get
from A to B to C to D to e you know
whatever it has to promise lots of
conflict the emotion of a movie and the
emotion of any scene is primarily going
to grow out of the conflict if it's not
the conflict being faced right then it's
the conflict that they are anticipating
or occasionally that the audience is
anticipating there have to be those
human feelings and desires and fears
that we can relate to if it's not coming
out of here
it's not worth it it's just
imagination
it's good up to a point but it has to
have an emotional truth in its simplest
form a story is The Human Experience
there's something in there that's
scaring you and that's good
you need to go there they don't care
your smartness that's not important they
want the guts because that's what they
want
that's what they pay for for the writers
to go through the process of exploring
Excavating pulling apart looking at all
the elements of a story that they know
better than anybody else everything that
you can do to put a little something
down to to create a bit of something for
your creativity to hang on to you know I
want people to just jump into it and
write a story in 30 minutes and then
kind of walk away and go I can do it and
this is like yeah you can keep your
voice that's the most important thing I
was a it's like don't lose your voice
don't lose your instincts your childlike
instincts for telling stories as Garrett
just said be brave be bold and mighty
forces will come to your Aid you got
story to tell so